all right we want to revisit now a
debate that we had earlier about otto
beckham jr and whether his comments
about making the browns the new patriots
are over the line
i still think they are chris and i've
managed to come up with a few instances
where someone has kind of called their
shot joe namath super bowl three the
bears i had a reader point this out they
recorded the super bowl shuffle video
weeks before they even qualified to play
in the super bowl and then plexico burst
before super bowl 42 when they went in
and you know the the the the uh giants
took down goliath that year uh and
burris called his shot and said that the
giants would beat the patriots i mean
but it's still
it's one thing to talk about a game it's
one thing to make the boast late in the
year i can't think of a time where
months before the season even begins
you've got this kind of stuff going on
and anyone actually delivering on it i i
just think there's too many things that
can happen it sets the bar too high it
puts too much pressure on people in
those early season games because you
know we talk about this all the time now
if you start off one and two two and
four your window gets narrower and
narrower and it's harder to get the
things you need like home field
advantage and i think it puts more
pressure on these teams that feel like
they have to win week one they have to
win week two and and i don't you know
maybe the browns will rise up and
they'll run the table who knows maybe
two years after going on 16 they go 16-0
i just think that this extra pressure
doesn't help and i think it's got to
drive freddie kitchens crazy because
he's the guy who's going to take the
blame chris if this team fails to live
up to its sky-high expectations yes he
will uh the pressure was there already
with the before odell beckham jr said
these comments that's where i'll at
least defend him there i mean we've
talked about this every week for about
the last month and a half uh just the
brown
chris yeah wouldn't this have been an
opportunity when he's asked by gq last
night at the met gala with his tuxedo
with the sleeves ripped off well and i
don't i don't diss the look if you can
pull it off pull it off but wouldn't it
be better to say you know man people are
just really over the top and their
expectations of browns we have to prove
it one week at a time we got a lot of
work to do before anybody considers us a
team that's done anything i'm ready to
do it i'm anxious for the challenge but
this is not going to be easy i mean
what's wrong with saying something like
that no i i understand that's probably
an answer that you or me would have you
know given to the media if that were the
case but again i'm not going to sit here
and look at odell beckham jr's comments
and just go oh gosh he made some crazy
proclamation i mean hey trying to bring
as many championships there as possible
you know we want to turn we were turning
the browns into the new patriots you
know he's kind of just trying to say
yeah we're setting it's a new era in
cleveland there's nothing wrong with him
saying that he's saying that they want
to start something new they want to
create a new culture they want it to be
a winning culture and they aspire to be
new england like he's not calling a shot
and says we're going to win super bowls
he said trying to so i get it uh guess
it's not the most perfect answer in the
world but i don't look at it you know
nearly as egregious as greedy williams
last week talking about the super bowls
when he hasn't even gone through a
practice yet in the nfl okay and this is
not a super bowl type comment this is
just talking about what they're trying
to do he's excited to be a part of it
and that's how i look at it at least
yeah and here's the other thing too it's
critical to have self-awareness and i
think he has some but not enough because
it's too late to undo
the persona that he's created over the
past five years he's at the met gala for
crying out loud i mean this guy's a big
deal everything he says is going to
carry much greater significance and if
it was some
slappy back up right tackle he has to
know that before he says anything in the
chat and you know he can get mad and he
can get salty and he can get pissy and
he can block me again on twitter
actually have to unblock me first but
that's part of the reality of being
self-aware he needs to understand that
for a guy like him you say it people are
going to listen it's like the old ef
hutton commercials that's long before
your time these do a commercial all the
time when you watch football games and
there would be people in a room and and
somebody would say something everybody
stop and listen it was at ef hutton it
was some brokerage firm when ef hutton
speaks people listen right when odell
beckham jr speaks people listen so be
careful what you say that's all i'm
going to say about okay that's something
else you want to see no no
i think we hit it all i mean yeah we
i think we both agree we wish he would
have phrased it differently but it's not
the worst thing in the world
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports